on this Wednesday checkup I want to talk
about the two urgent care doctors that
are making headlines for their
controversial statements regarding kovat
19 this all started on April 22nd when
two doctors Dan Erickson and art Massey
he called a press conference to discuss
their thoughts on Cova 19 and the
reopening of America based on the 5,000
patients they tested in their urgent
care centers the main takeaways from the
press conference are as follows one the
government is horribly miss handling the
situation by ignoring the science and
only focusing on controlling the public
to way more people are sick with kovat
19 than is currently reported 3 the
fatality rate of covin 18 is much lower
than currently being reported and it's
similar to the flu and finally for that
America should reopen now because the
harms of keeping it closed much outweigh
the benefits in the days following their
press conference they received
nationwide attention mostly because
their recommendations and opinions were
in stark contrast with the medical
community and the CDC also the video of
the press conference became increasingly
popular on social media where picked up
over 5 million views on YouTube and it
received retweets from popular figures
like Elon Musk who supported the doctors
fast forward to April 27th and YouTube
has now taken the video down stating
that it's broken Community Guidelines
basically saying that there's a lot of
misinformation in it and there's been a
joint statement released by the American
College of Emergency Physicians and the
American Academy of emergency medicine
let me read that statement the AEC P and
AAE M jointly and emphatically condemned
the recent opinions released by dr.
Erickson and dr. masini these reckless
and untested musings do not speak for
medical societies and are inconsistent
with current science and epidemiology
regarding kovat 19 as owners of local
urgent care clinics it appears these two
individuals are releasing biased non
peer-reviewed data to advance their
personal financial interests without
regard for the public's health I
completely agree with these statements
because these individuals presented so
much misinformation that it's further
gonna confuse the general public let me
explain why the information these
doctors presented is just not
scientifically act
look the fact that they tested 5000
patients in their urgent care centers
and 6% of them tested positive for Cova
19 makes a lot of sense and it's
actually probably accurate but what's
not accurate and what does it make sense
is to then take 6% that number and
assume that if you test all of New York
State or all of California then 6% of
those people will also test positive
that's just not how statistics work the
people that go to an urgent care center
are more likely to test positive because
they're showing symptoms because they
likely had exposure to kovat 19 that's
why they're there in general when you're
testing a pre-selected population like
that you're gonna have higher numbers
it's like assuming that if you go to
Southern California and gather the
weather data you can then extrapolate it
and assume that the weather is the same
in New York and then with the incorrect
assumption that 6 percent of the general
public must be kovat positive they go on
to calculate a fatality rate that's
similar to the flu let me go ahead and
explain to you how we calculate a death
rate so it all makes sense first we take
all the people who've died with kovat 19
and we divide that number by all the
people who have been infected with kovat
19 let's run an example here if 10
people have died of kovat 19 and a
thousand have been infected either by 10
by a thousand and you get 1% it makes a
1% death rate now if you incorrectly
assume that way more people have had
kovat 19 than is true you can
artificially lower this death rate my
second issue is let's go ahead and
assume their calculations are correct
they're not it doesn't change the fact
that kovat 19 is still much more
dangerous than the flu reason being that
colvett 19 spreads out at two to three
times faster rate than the flu which
means that it can overwhelm our hospital
systems in the blink of an eye in fact
that's what the purpose of all these
lockdowns were to ease the strain on our
hospital systems so we can continue
taking care of patients that are not
only suffering with kovat but with all
the other medical elements out there if
you would have been in a car accident
there's been no one to help you if you
call for a heart attack there would have
been no one to help you we must also
remember that for the flu we have a
vaccine we have an fda-approved
treatment so by maintaining the lockdown
for a slightly longer period of time
we're buying Thai
in order to get there to get the vaccine
and to get the treatments authorized
these are all the reasons why I've been
consistently saying on my youtube
channel to my patients on television
that while COBIT 19 looks similar to the
flu to virus upper respiratory symptoms
they are not the same they are
fundamentally different in that kovat 19
spreads so quickly and puts such a
tremendous strain on our healthcare
system that it can break it in fact I'd
love for these emergency medicine
physicians who are no longer working in
emergency rooms to come to New York City
and talk to the ER doctors that are
working on the front lines to see how
overwhelmed they were with this
apparently mild virus during its peak
let's move on to the topic of reopening
America these individuals are adamant
about reopening America right now
because they're talking about the
negative consequences that are happening
as a result of this lockdown social
issues like domestic violence and child
abuse patients not being able to get
care because they're worried about
getting sick with kovat routine
procedures being rescheduled economic
harms all of these negative consequences
are very true and we need to take them
into consideration when we're weighing
the benefits verse harms of a lockdown
the last thing we want to do is to rush
to reopen America haphazardly and see a
spike in the resurgence of kovat 19
cases possibly destroying our health
care system potentially putting
thousands if not millions of lives at
risk because they might not be able to
get care at a hospital
look we absolutely need to start taking
steps in reopening America if we
continue this for much longer there's
gonna be limited benefit and more harms
being added on but the way we do this is
strategically we open certain areas
first and we continuously gather
information to see what impact we're
having on Cova 19 numbers and then use
that data to gradually reopen the
country slowly carefully and most
importantly safely at the end of the day
no one benefits from keeping America
close in fact this whole theory of
politicians keeping America close just
to keep control over the general public
is nonsense
they're getting hurt by this too and so
are their families if you're gonna be a
public facing medical professional that
goes on to talk about kovat 19 and say
that you're talking about science at
least do it accurately and keep the
politics out of it these doctors aren't
the first to be spreading misinformation
about kovat 19 so are politicians and so
is the media click here for those videos
and as always stay happy and healthy
[Music]